[Música]
estas son las cinco profesiones mejor
pagadas en mexico en el primer trimestre
el 2021 y todas tienen una relación en
todas hay matemáticas en sus planes de
estudio y la verdad es que ya casi no
hay profesiones en las que no haya
matemáticas el informe de empleos
emergentes nos muestra algunas de las
profesiones que van a liderar los
mercados y esto me hace pensar todavía
tenemos estudiantes que deciden su
profesión porque no quieren estudiar
matemáticas
actualmente en méxico la mayoría de
profesionistas está en el área de
ciencias sociales o administrativas
tenemos una sobreoferta de contadores y
administradores de diseñadores etcétera
y en estas profesiones también se
estudia matemáticas pero la verdadera
oferta laboral está en las ciencias
exactas
hacen falta químicos hacen falta
matemáticos economistas o como decían
hace rato hacen falta científicos además
de que aquí están las profesiones
mejores pagadas y las que vienen en los
empleos emergentes
y el hecho de que nuestros estudiantes
no quieran estar matemáticas fue una de
las principales razones que me llevó a
dedicarme a la enseñanza de las
matemáticas para que cada vez menos
estudiantes decidan su profesión su
futuro solo porque no quieren estudiar
matemáticas
y esto para que me va a servir profe
quien de ustedes no pregunto esta
declaración matemáticas no yo estoy
seguro que más de alguno no y mira lo
que pasa es que cuando estamos en la
escuela puede pasar alguna de estas
cosas no nos dijeron cómo se relacionaba
lo que estábamos viendo en la escuela
con la vida nos dijeron o nos hicieron
creer que teníamos que memorizar
fórmulas y repetirlas solamente en un
examen o cuando éramos pequeñas nos
hicieron aprendernos las tablas de
multiplicar y ojo aquí no no me
malentiendan no quiere decir que las
tablas de multiplicar nos sirvan o
simplemente que no creo que sea útil
torturar a niños de 89 años pensando en
que tienen que memorizar sé eso y si no
lo logran pues terminan frustrados y ya
no quieren saber nada de las matemáticas
y luego cuando son grandes pues deciden
su profesión sólo porque no quieren o
tomaron un odio hacia las matemáticas no
alguien sabe qué es esto
es el teorema de pitágoras ahora alguien
me puede decir si lo ha utilizado en su
trabajo o si lo ha utilizado en su vida
yo sé la respuesta seguramente nunca y
no es porque el tema de pitágoras no se
utilice para nada la verdad es que hay
gente como nosotros que no lo utilizamos
pero sí que hay gente que utiliza el
teorema de pitágoras todos los días
nosotros aprendemos matemáticas desde el
preescolar
vamos al preescolar y ahí nos enseña no
conocemos los números nos enseñan a
contar nos enseñan a medir con palabras
no pequeño grande largo corto nos
enseñan a reconocer figuras geométricas
después vamos a pasar a primaria y aquí
es la parte más importante para aprender
matemáticas porque aquí tenemos que ser
capaces de enfrentarnos a cualquier
situación en la que haya números y aquí
entre otras cosas aprendemos las
operaciones básicas aprendemos a
calcular porcentajes aprendemos a
resolver problemas y aprendemos también
las tablas de multiplicar y las
terribles fracciones luego vamos a
secundaria y aquí el conocimiento es
complementario ahora necesitamos lo que
aprendimos en primaria para seguir aquí
ya se ven cosas como los números
negativos se ve un poco una introducción
al álgebra teorema de pitágoras
justamente áreas y perímetros
probabilidades y luego vamos a prepa y
aquí como se acordarán de la cosa se
pone más complicada porque ya el álgebra
es más avanzada se ve geometría
analítica trigonometría combinatoria
cálculo y todo eso para qué
esta pregunta no puede contestar un
maestro de manera sencilla y no es culpa
del profe es culpa de la sociedad porque
todos creemos que lo que aprendemos en
la escuela lo tenemos que utilizar todos
los días en el trabajo y no es así
lamento decirles que el 90% o más de lo
que aprendemos en la escuela no nos va a
servir para nada tal vez vamos a
necesitar contar algunas cosas medir
algunas cosas y para eso pues ya tengo
el celular no se acabó mi problema pedro
entonces para qué vamos a la escuela si
acaba decir que no sirve para nada
pero yo creo que no necesitamos nada más
esas cosas
cada día dependemos más de la tecnología
del internet las computadoras el celular
las redes sociales los videojuegos
detrás de todo eso hay un montón de
matemáticas todo está hecho con
matemáticas por eso necesitamos formar a
nuestros niños con matemáticas para que
ellos sean capaces de entender cómo
funciona eso sacarle el mejor provecho o
crear nuevas tecnologías entonces qué
les parece si cambiamos la pregunta si
en lugar de preguntar y eso para que me
va a servir pregunto porque tenemos que
aprender eso esa pregunta si la podemos
contestar porque las matemáticas nos
desarrollan ese pensamiento matemático
ese pensamiento matemático que nos da la
habilidad habilidades como resolver
problemas elaborar estrategias tomar
decisiones y eso sí que nos va a servir
en la vida todos los días necesitamos
las tres habilidades
esta forma de pensar nos hace discernir
información relevante de la que no es
relevante ahora con un clic tenemos
acceso a toda la información del mundo
entonces saber clasificar esa
información se convierte en crucial de
esta forma de pensar nos hace
preguntarnos por qué funcionan las cosas
cómo funcionan las cosas la lógica que
hay detrás de todo lo que pasa entonces
en general esta forma de pensar nos
ayuda a resolver y plantear problemas
que se nos presenten en nuestro trabajo
en la escuela en la sociedad en nuestra
vida y a eso venimos a la escuela a
formarnos como personas eso hace el
pensamiento matemático
a pesar de todo esto yo sigo teniendo
muchos estudiantes y muchos conocidos
que me dicen hoy pedro a mí las
matemáticas no se me dan eso eso es nada
más para los inteligentes está muy
difícil eso
pero yo creo que todos tenemos una parte
matemática esta parte matemática tiene
tres elementos el primero es las
creencias o el cómo nosotros apreciamos
o percibimos la ciencia el segundo es
como aprendemos en la escuela y el
tercero son nuestras habilidades si
alguien dice o cree que es malo en
matemáticas ya tiene un punto en contra
si a esto le sumamos como lo aprendió en
la escuela pues seguramente va a tener
una mala experiencia de dallas de las
matemáticas como cambiar esta imagen
negativa como quitar estas malas
experiencias bueno yo hoy les voy a
proponer dos cosas la primera va a ser
entender el fútbol como las matemáticas
perdón como el fútbol
imagínate que tú quieres enseñarle el
fútbol a un niño y solamente lo pones a
tirar penales
qué va a pasar después de algunos cinco
o diez penales este niño se va a aburrir
ya no va a querer jugar fútbol jamás es
que aburrido es esto no lo mismo ocurre
con las matemáticas si tú a un niño le
quiere esencial matemáticas solamente lo
pones a resolver 50 ejercicios lo tiene
que hacer lo mismo seguramente a enfadar
y si no lo logra
peor aún se va a frustrar y jamás va
quiere saber nada las matemáticas no
pongo este ejemplo porque me gustan
mucho las matemáticas y el fútbol cuando
era niño era muy malo para las
matemáticas y también para el fútbol
ok soy malo para el fútbol todavía no
pero ya puedo jugar con mis amigos y
apoyar a un partido bueno cuando cuando
estás en un equipo de fútbol durante
toda la semana tienes que entrenar todos
los días entrenas
conoces las reglas del fútbol haces
entrenamientos físicos
acondicionamientos bueno lo técnico y
todo esto para el fin de semana poder
llegar a jugar un partido
y yo no he visto que ningún niño diga
profe y esto para que me va a servir
jamás
simplemente van y juegan no y tampoco he
visto a un futbolista profesional hacer
esto en un partido me sigues todo le
sirve para algo pero no lo haces el día
del partido bueno lo mismo ocurre con
las matemáticas tú no puedes construir
un puente así nada más aquí falta un
puente yo lo voy a construir no puedes
ni tampoco puedes invertir en la bolsa
así nada más necesitas haber entrenado a
tu cerebro conocer las reglas de las
matemáticas cómo funcionan cómo se
comportan y entonces si elaborar muchas
estrategias resolver muchos problemas
tener creatividad y entonces si tal vez
ya puedes hacer esto de verdad las
matemáticas son como el fútbol uno no
necesita ser cristiano ronaldo para
jugar un partido fútbol pero tampoco
necesitas ser gauss para hacer
matemáticas no el punto 2 es cambiar la
forma en la que transmitimos y pensamos
las matemáticas
las matemáticas se transmiten de manera
negativa en dos lugares en la escuela y
fuera de la escuela en la escuela como
lo dije antes cuando te ponen a repetir
un montón de ejercicios donde tienes que
hacer lo mismo una y otra vez entonces
te frustras te aburres lo que sea mala
experiencia segunda mala experiencia
todos aquí todos aquí nos han de haber
pedido en algún momento ayuda para una
tarea matemáticas no el si yo te ayudo
que tienes que hacer para resolver un
problema donde hay que hacer operaciones
con fracciones uy no no no no no no no
fracciones no horrible no no no eso yo
nunca lo aprendí está muy difícil que
estás haciendo aquí le estás
transmitiendo a un niño ese miedo el
niño va a pensar si un adulto no lo
puede resolver porque quieren que lo
resuelva yo
eso está horrible entonces estas cosas
que generan que los alumnos vengan a la
escuela y crean pues que los problemas
nada más tiene una solución que esa
solución en la que el profe dice no hay
otra que tenemos que memorizarlo y al
final no me sirve para nada la vida pero
yo creo que no es así yo pienso que
todos hacemos matemáticas todos los días
todos los días ordenamos cosas todos los
días contamos cosas todos los días
resolvemos un problema del que sea no
tiene que ser cálculos ok entonces lo
que trato de decirles es si si todos
fuéramos conscientes de todos los
momentos en los que aplicamos
matemáticas y si lo hiciéramos saber a
nuestros niños tal vez ellos para ellos
sería más sencillo relacionarlo con lo
que ven en la escuela ok yo tengo dos
ejemplos
este es el primero aquí hay tres rutas
desde aquí al aeropuerto san jose de
todo se emociona algún momento el
aeropuerto no piensa en un segundo cual
ruta tomarías
yo creo que todos aquí alguno ha de
haber sido cualquiera de los tres no
importa pero todo esto como lo hiciste
con matemáticas aunque no hayas hecho
ningún cálculo porque porque yo te puse
un problema tú dependiendo de las
condiciones evitar el tráfico apreciar
la vista o vierte muy rápido y pagar que
acepta lo que sea uno quiere pagar
caseta cualquiera de esas condiciones tú
las pensaste entonces hubo un problema
hubo condiciones pensa elabora hazte una
estrategia todo esto muy rápido tomaste
una decisión resolviste el problema de
esto se tratan las matemáticas a eso se
viene la escuela
necesitamos matemáticas hasta para
acomodar las maletas en un avión
ah
gracias
lo que digo es porque no hacemos de las
matemáticas un hábito
algo que sea normal entre nosotros algo
que no nos asuste y no estoy diciendo
que te pongas con tu hijo el fin de
semana y se sienten a recitar las tablas
de multiplicar no digo que te puedes
sentar en familia con tus hijos y jugar
algún juego estrategia esos juegos en
los que tienes que pensar cómo ganarle a
los demás ahí hay un montón de
matemáticas porque estás pensando en
cómo resolver algo juegos como el dominó
el ajedrez el monopoly o el adivina
quién hace unas semanas en un
entrenamiento de matemáticas un alumno
me decía profe sabes que podemos
calcular la probabilidad de ganar en la
adivina quién eso está genial hacer
preguntas no por hacerlas sino hacer una
pregunta pensando en cuál es cuál es que
me va a preguntar la otra persona para
ganar eso es lo que tenemos que hacer
hacer ese tipo de juegos hacer un
presupuesto familiar cuánto tenemos en
el mes tenemos que gastar esto ahí hay
matemáticas está resolviendo un problema
real y aunque sean solo sumas o que lo
hagas en la calculadora eso no importa
cuando salgas te invito a que voltees a
tu alrededor que busques formas que
busques patrones que busques matemáticas
porque lo bonito de las matemáticas es
pensar algo que las máquinas no pueden
hacer gracias
[Aplausos]